there's a new hierarchy in town and it's
the hierarchy of Silicon Valley to the
people who run these companies there is
an astonishing sense of power but in the
last 12 months there's been a
realization that as they say in the
spider-man movies with great power comes
great responsibility and a great deal of
trouble too if you don't know how to
manage that responsibility
so of course Neal most of those probably
all almost all of those Silicon Valley
internet billionaires would have
preferred Hillary Clinton have comprised
the United States and she didn't
so to their utter horror and it really
was it was really kind of fascinating to
watch up close they found that the
network platforms they'd created could
be used to achieve the opposite of what
they had intended it was not the Clinton
administration campaign that knew how to
use Facebook to target advertising in
order to secure the swing states
it was the Trump campaign it was Steve
Bannon and Jared Kushner
not to mention Russian intelligence but
we are in the midst of a great exposure
which is not over that is going to
reveal the extent to which Trump
campaign in a large way and the Russian
intelligence network in a small way used
Facebook and to a lesser extent other
platforms to achieve victory in the 2016
presidential election and I argue in the
book and I stand by it that Donald Trump
would not be president today if there
had not been Facebook and Twitter and
the other platforms that were used in a
conventional traditional American
election campaign he would have been
defeated because he would have been
outspent Hillary Clinton outspent Donald
Trump two to one more than two to one on
standard cable and terrestrial
television advertising he would have
lost so this was a hugely significant
moment in American political history I
still don't think people realize the
extent to which it depended on the use
of Facebook in particular